next one is about used cars this one is
uh graphic language so if you're
watching
and you're a child close your eyes close
your ears card totaled
used prices are crazy right now no way i
can afford new can i please get some
advice before i have to get another bad
loan
yeah sounds like a lot of people right
now some [ __ ]
hit my parked car and totally i was
paying 18 apr
ridiculous i know but payments were very
manageable and that was all that's
mattered to me lately
insurance paid off the remaining loan
and i'm getting two thousand dollars
back to put down on a new car
i had a few grand of savings but coveted
made quick work of that
oh and they're only giving me one stupid
week of rental coverage to find a new
car
the used car market is [ __ ] absurd
right now
back when i got my first shitty loan at
least i was able to afford a close to
new well-equipped economy car now all i
can afford is [ __ ] that's close to 10
years old without even a rear view
camera i was expecting that to say
mirror but it said camera
and i'll still be paying basically the
same price in the interest rates as i
was before i've never missed a payment
in my two and a half years
of my other car loan or any payment on
anything for that matter and i still
only have a 620 credit score
i've never even gotten a credit card so
i guess that has a lot to do with it
anyway what should i do overpay on some
definite
[ __ ] box that will just make me angry
every time i look at my payments
ask my dad with good credit to co-sign
something with me buy something newer
fix my credit and try to refinance later
or buy a 3 000 beater on craigslist i
really don't know i would appreciate any
advice finances aren't my strong suit as
you can probably tell
don't buy a nice new one go get one that
is actually going to be
reliable and if
necessary get your dad to co-sign it
with you
but you're putting a burden on your dad
so
first option would absolutely be take
your two thousand dollars put it as a
down payment get a card that you know is
going to be reliable
and try to make sure that the price the
price that you're paying right now
isn't gonna get compounded by buying a
bad car then you're going to do a bunch
of service on later
right like people forget if every month
you got to go get 500
worth of service done on your bad car
then you might as well just paid up for
the nicer car
and cars end up being one of these
things that
when it doesn't work it doesn't work
right for most things if you got engine
problems or something like you're not
going anywhere
so very quickly the cost of getting
around that can compound but i think
that's like the simplest thing is just
get a reliable car put the 2 000 down
and try to get something in the you know
maybe six seven thousand dollar range
yeah i think that's smart and you don't
i don't know why he needs a car with a
rear view camera but
well that that depends on if it's a nice
car or not i guess
yeah but 10 years old one is really not
that old for a car right like
i mean it's old but it's not you can get
something with good mileage for that and
pay a few that my
what i would do in this situation is i
would get something for a few thousand
dollars
if you don't can't pay for it cash
reform you get some of the costs so the
rate comes down
and then uh just get something that's
more reliable you don't need something
necessarily flashy your goal at this
point is to optimize for how long it
lasts right so
get something that has the best track
record of lasting for a long time low
mileage
doesn't have any accidents something
like that and uh just spend a few
thousand dollars on it i don't know what
his old car was but the
one of the first things i would do too
is check your insurance and make sure
that they gave you a reasonable quote
for what your car was worth at the time
a lot of the times they just go off you
know the kelly blue book value of your
car yeah you got to fight it right yeah
which isn't necessarily the actual true
value of your car
just go in your local area find comps
find something that is
with the insurance with the insurance
and just make sure they're giving you a
fair value for your car right they're
incentivized not to pay you the full
value of what you're
owed or deserved um and i see that all
the time and
i've personally known a bunch of people
if you fight it you will get a better um
so you're saying that even though the
insurance company's telling them that
he's only gonna get two thousand dollars
for the car
you think that maybe they can get up to
twenty five hundred or three thousand
paid off part of the loan that was
already on the car so they obviously
gave him some money so say
the whole loan and what he's getting
cash is five thousand dollars
you're they're saying your car was worth
five thousand dollars at the time um
so just make sure that if you go and
search for cars in your area and you try
to buy your exact same car
how much would it cost you to do and
just make sure you're getting the fair
value for it that's a great point
because the used car
prices have exploded and so likely you
can go to them and say hey
i know that you said it was only worth
five thousand dollars but right now
here's three in my area
that are similar mileage similar make
model etc and they're going for 7 500
bucks
and maybe they'll give you the full 7
500 but maybe they get you up to six or
seven thousand dollars so you can get
more money
right is one way to attack it the second
thing is then what do you go buy
yeah it goes back to the concept of
saving versus going to earn more money
right if you can increase the insurance
payout by 50
100 by showing them uh comparable sales
then that gets you a lot more leeway
than it does to try and go save a few
months of income to go buy something
i just saw i just quickly googled while
you guys were talking miami craigslist
and i just typed in cars and literally
2013 gmc yukon
xl 500 bucks down everyone drives
and so i don't know how legit this place
is but it basically says that
uh regardless of credit bad credit no
credit first time buyer
anything uh give them a call they can
help and it's 500 bucks down for a 2013
gmc yukon
uh and so you know you can kind of
quickly scroll through this and what you
realize is
there's even things like um if we go all
the way down you can see
a 2013 subaru
impreza that somebody is selling
for two thousand dollars down right so
these are cars that
2010 11 12 13 14 that you can
end up buying and some of them are
through
various uh brokers but to me that is
that's the that's the move hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it
you